aujourd'hui un sujet un peu sérieux et
un titre un peu plus ta clique
alors ce que je veux dire c'est pas
forcément que l'éducation de ses rares
mais c'est pas du tout que l'éducation
ne sait rien en question ça sert à
quelque chose
mais le point de cette vidéo c'est que
l'éducation n'est pas la solution
l'ancien sous je pense que on attend
celui donné beaucoup trop d'importance
et malheureusement il ya quand même pas
mal de donner pas mal d'études
scientifiques qui suggère que c'est plus
compliqué que ça et en particulier il ya
un grave qui m'a fait qu'ils ont un peu
déprimé tu m'a même pas me déprimer
c'est le graphe que je galère appelle le
graphe du désespoir et une section de
vidéos de devant que sur ce graphe
donc c'est un graphe où on voit
l'évolution de tout cas là le degré de
crédence de différents sujets à la
question la phrase est ce qu'il ya des
données solides en faveur de d'une cause
humaine du réchauffement climatique
est ce qu'on voit sur ce grave c'est que
plus les gens sont éduqués ou même plus
précisément plus disons ce qu'on appelle
de l'intelligence scientifique donc d'un
milliard dans ses calculs et c'est
essentiellement mesuré comme étant la
capacité à appliquer les raisonnements
des sciences à avoir aussi des
connaissances scientifiques et à les
appliquer à dans des cas pratiques
vraiment j'ai envie dire c'est un
logement et éthique c'est vraiment ce
que cherche vraiment finalement
augmenter cette intelligence
scientifique l'impression en tout cas et
beaucoup de vulgarisation va également
dans ce sens on sent que ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens et pourtant après le
graff
ça a créé des divergences absolument
énorme
en particulier une bonne proportion des
gens qui ont vivement une très bonne
intelligence scientifique mais qui sont
qui nie complètement un changement
climatique
lorsqu'elle de l'origine anthropique du
fonds climatique et ce qu'on voit aussi
c'est que tout ça est très liée à du
raisonnement motivés puisque très très
tôt puisque la divergence dépend très
fortement quasiment essentiellement deux
du parti pris politique de l individu et
ça en fait on en a déjà parlé dans la
série étant sur la démocratie alors ce
que vous avez parlé intel
rationnellement irrationnel où vous avez
parlé de la manière dont les gens votent
et il semble que les gens votent selon
leur leurs préférences sociétale et non
pas selon leur situation individuelle
mais malheureusement la manière dont ils
votent et est également extrêmement
partisanes et une expérience de dan
karan qui le montrent de façon alarmante
il s'agit d'un emprunt de maths et
lorsqu'on pose le problème de maths avec
un exemple tout à fait soit sur lequel
on a peu d'attachement politique comme
par exemple est ce que il crème dont on
connaît même pas la marque un effet ou
non un effet positif ou bâle et les
jambes
certains sont plus ou moins bon va dire
que le taux de réussite est un peu plus
bas que ce que j'espérais mais skis mais
ce qu'on voit c'est que les gens ont de
l'intelligence scientifique puis sont
capables plutôt fins puces sont bons en
maths plus il arrive à résoudre ce
problème
de manière juste bon jusque là rien de
surprises mais dire que l'éducation sert
à quelque chose l'éducation est une
solution mais ce qui est vraiment
effrayant c'est ce qui se passe lorsque
on change
l'énoncé on le rend très pratiquant par
exemple en parlant de du port d'armes
qui est un sujet très chaud aux états
unis eh bien on se rend compte que la
qualité d'aidé réponse dépend beaucoup
plus du parti politique préférée du
sujet que de ses compétences
mathématiques
en fait on voit même sur ce graphe que
les la capacité à trouver la bonne
réponse
des croix initialement avec la plaisance
mathématiques de la personne si la bonne
réponse au problème mathématique dans
l'encontre des préférences politiques de
la personne interrogée à savoir que ce
soit du côté des démocrates et des
républicains de tous les partis
politiques
il semble en tout cas un certain degré
d'éducation est insuffisant il faut
vraiment aller vers ceux qui sont
vraiment bons en maths et même ceux qui
sont très bons en maths en fait ils sont
en fait aussi bons que ceux qui sont pas
du tout bon en maths c'est vraiment
vraiment quelque chose
découverte absolument effrayante de se
rendre compte que finalement sur les
sujets dès que ça devient un peu
politique dès que ça vient politisé des
cons on sent on a un parti pris un
énorme dès qu'on fait du raisonnement
motivé finalement ballet question n'est
absolument pas la solution ça suggère
que d'une part politiser les choses est
extrêmement dangereux puisque ça va
renforcer le raisonnement motivé ce qui
va anéantir notre capacité à bien
réfléchir
en l'occurrence à bien résoudre ce
problème donc autant que possible je
pense qu'il faut éviter de rendre les
choses politiques
ça aide juste à mieux réfléchir est ce
que ça montre aussi c'est que
l'éducation dans ce genre de situation
n'êtes pas voir et potentiellement
néfastes et s'inquiètent car elle
explique simplement du fait qu'on est en
mode raisonnement motivé on va chercher
tous les arguments possibles si on
intègre en trouve plus arguments et puis
après si on est dans votre raisonnement
au pied on va juste retenir les
arguments qui vont dans ce sens et on va
oublier tout le reste du coup ça va nous
faire beaucoup plus d'arguments
qui confirme ce que l'on veut croire et
du coup ces empires la situation donc là
l'éducation ça semble vraiment pas être
la solution du cac d'éducation seul ça
al'air potentiellement même néfaste
[Musique]
alors il est pas mal d'autres raisons
pour lesquelles l'éducation pourrait ne
pas être vraiment la solution comme par
exemple le fait que juste changer le
programme scolaire et le rang de
meilleur en fait c'est extrêmement
difficile
donc j'ai interdit néanmoins gilles
dowek qui avait cherché depuis des
décennies introduire de l'informatique à
l'école et galère pas possible et voilà
ça ça vient petit à petit mais s'il faut
des décennies et puis on a dit que ce
sera bien fait parce que normalement il
ya des problèmes de ressources humaines
quand il faut des gens pour enseigner
cette discipline et il en faut beaucoup
si on veut enseigner dans toutes les
tous les lycées pour tous les collèges
de france il ya un entrepreneur
explication c'est que ça ne touche que
les jeunes or aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de théories qui sont très très douteuse
et qui sont amies dangereuse de mai
compréhension des enjeux sanitaires des
enjeux de société du changement
climatique du numérique il est tellement
dans le jeu qui sont tellement complexes
aujourd'hui que on n'a pas faim c'est
pas raisonnable il me semble d'attendre
la prochaine et que la prochaine
génération résolve ses problèmes il faut
résoudre aussi demandé aujourd'hui et
pourrait résoudre dès aujourd'hui il
faut enfoncer les preneurs de décisions
dès aujourd'hui et ça d'éducation
malheureusement ne les touche pas mais
enfin de la chose il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques très reconnu je veux pas
citer de noms mais facilement imaginer
quelqu'un qui a fait la une de
l'actualité beaucoup trop souvent cette
année qui ont été parfaitement éduqués
qui mène des équipes de scientifiques
qui ont des thèses en sciences et dont
le niveau épistémique et
voire très discutable donc j'ai
l'éducation même à bac + beaucoup
salaires ne pas suffire
mais là on a un argument encore plus
dévastateurs qui est le fait que fait
l'éducation pourrait même être néfaste
c'est vraiment déprimant parce qu'on a
envie de dire si on n'a pas une question
qu'est ce qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est un peu
à l'éducation si même l'éducation ne
fonctionne pas qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour nos sociétés pour améliorer
le niveau épistémique d'une société
vient pour aujourd'hui je vais vous
laisser avec cette remarque un peu
déprimante mais on en parlera de la
prochaine fois de pistes de solutions
qui ont été notamment découverts par ce
même dany carrel qui sont prometteuses
qui sont loin d'être la solution ultime
mais vu le constat avec une même
l'éducation peut-être non seulement pas
assez productive et même néfastes qui
aurait dit on a vraiment besoin de
chercher tout ce qui peut nous aider à
aller dans un sens d'une meilleure
niveau épistémique et de l'ensemble de
la population et de noël